[Music]
hello
welcome to step into the sunlight cloud
computing and devops work after coven
19.
this is part of our step into the
sunlight series of webinars
from simplylearn and our guest today is
matthew david
digital leader from accenture a little
bit more about him in a moment
matthew david is a digital leader from
accenture
which is one of the leading consulting
companies in the world
and he has published
13 books he's also a
leader in the technologies of cloud
devops
artificial intelligence and blockchain
and we're um very glad to have him
well it's fantastic to be here with
stuart
go ahead matthew i'll ask you the first
question okay
how is cloud computing and devops how
are these fields going to evolve
as we come out of this pandemic so i
think that's a very good
question and uh one of the areas of
focus
that um i've always applied to
my career over the last 25 years
has always been what is the next
five-year horizon for
technology and um
and i i do this every year um i do it
more formally
and last couple of years with simply
learn uh we actually put out
a an e-book which is a forecast for what
we see is going to happen
in uh the following year and one of the
things i
always consider is you know is there an
x factor that will change
things so so for instance in 2007 you
could argue that the x factor
was see steve jobs releasing the iphone
and
completely changing the market as we saw
it
um nobody could have seen what was
happening with
covert 19. that was it is an
unprecedented
uh event that has affected every single
person
globally um and there there's there's uh
no restriction on who can get the covert
19
um and so there has been some very
um dramatic changes in our lifestyle
because of that
what's interesting i was just going to
say that
this is what nasty nicholas taylor calls
a black swan event
that's a very good way to define it and
and what's interesting though
when it comes specifically to cloud and
devops
is that a lot of companies have been
having either considering the migration
to cloud and devops
have started doing some work or have
moved to cloud and devops i
i would argue that there's a lot of
companies that are still in that middle
stage where they're considering
um and have done some migration with
the uh with the covet 19 shutdown that
we've experienced
in many ways it has accelerated our
digital mindset by five years
and for instance i was talking to my
neighbor a couple months
ago and and he was
amazed and surprised um around
technologies like zoom
he'd never use them hadn't had any calls
to use them in his business
and i mean i've i've been using them for
almost 20 years
and um and what it made me realize is
that
the mindset for many people just hasn't
been
on uh digital innovation leveraging
ai cloud devops other technologies
it's being on how do i get my job done
today very tactical
and so we've been forced to go forward
five years
and actually consider and bring in what
is the future so i i
you know earlier on we were talking
about um how i
see uh the two questions we asked at the
beginning of the session of you know how
you are feeling
um i will tell you every single day i
wake up and
there is i go through a split
personality
one side of me continues to be um
stressed and anxious by the events that
are happening
as part of curve 19. the other half of
me however
is extraordinarily optimistic about the
future
of our careers within cloud and devops i
mean it just
really is a shining area within
technology right now
so hopefully that helps address that
question
and and it's it's uh i think a lot of
people have that same kind of um
uh two-sided attitude that
you live in an uncertain time people
human beings don't deal well with
uncertainty
no no they really don't we all prefer to
know that the sun will come up tomorrow
and
we'll still have our jobs and our
families and
our health on the other hand
as you say the situation has created
new opportunities it really has well
positioned to take
advantage of those um this is going to
be
a good time to make career advancements
and
some great life changes it really is um
and i mean earlier on and when you're
introducing me
you know you see the term blockchain um
i would have
um i've been in i'm always interested in
emerging and
leading-edge technologies is just i just
gravitate towards that
and blockchain obviously is one of those
um
if you think of the the geithner hype
curve it's one of those early
technologies but i think we we will see
that if you invest your education into
what we're previously considered
emerging technologies
the acceleration to adoption for those
technologies is going to happen
much faster because we are in a world
where
you know in the us we've all been living
from home
for four months now and i think that
as we continue and look into the future
i'm not sure
how much of that is going to change over
the next four months
um you and i had a brief chat
and talking about technology adoption
and it's interesting
um cloud and devops are not really new
technologies in that
no no not at all um
i was it was interesting to think about
you know
it would be interesting to compare how
long it's taken for people to adopt
these technologies which is how long it
took
people in the early 20th century to
adopt
um the automobile from the from the time
of the
houseless carriage of you know ben's in
germany to the time that
people were drag racing down um colorado
boulevard and pasadena and sing songs
about it
so yeah but no i think you're absolutely
right i think that
um you know um that there are i think
there are three key barriers
for adoption of any new thing whether
it's a technology a lifestyle
whatever it is i think the first one is
a financial barrier
um you know that's that's always a given
the second is the uh the ease of
use um of the solution um
and you can certainly look at the
earlier cars i mean they were
expensive and they were difficult to use
um
and but that happens with all new
technologies when they come out
but then the third and the third one is
the most critical
it's the cultural buy-in are we
ready to adopt that technology
and you know you can certainly see
examples where people have come up with
what i would consider are really
clever and interesting technologies
but they the the cultural adoption
isn't there yet to accept them so a
google a good example
is uh google with the google glass we've
had google glass now for
six years uh six seven years and it's
just
it's never gotten out of being a niche
market
we also know that apple is working on a
similar technology they've been
incorporating their augmented reality
technology for
multiple years into their phones
but what the the difference between the
two of them is apple
um rightly or wrong is very good at
understanding
that cultural pivot point when we as
humans are ready to go to that next
level of technology
yeah google glass is a really good
example of that because
you know it was google tried to roll it
out as a consumer technology
a few years back and not only was there
not cultural acceptance there was
outright cultural rejection
where there were reported instances of
people being
assaulted for wearing google glasses
because of the
perceived invasion of privacy of the
people around them so
yeah absolutely technology has to
match the what they call the zeitgeist
of the the
economy in the and the marketplace
before it can be accepted
absolutely absolutely let's move on um
so
tell me about these particular changes
in devops that you see
sure so so there's a number of things
that are happening with devops and um
and and the one thing that i always
caution with any blanket statements you
make with devops is that
they're true for right now they will not
be true tomorrow
and what i mean by that is that the
advances in technologies and connected
technologies
with devops is happening at a breakneck
speed
and i think that this year that's only
been accelerated more
and we see this actually clearly with
what microsoft is doing
we see the same thing happening with
what i am amazon is doing with aws
um then we also see it with the number
of startups coming out with the
technologies so to go through what we
have here
um just a few key areas um
what i think that you'll start seeing
more of is just these
highly connected agile infrastructures
and so what do i mean by that
um highly connected in from a digital
point of view
but loosely connected and that we'll
move away from
big mammoth solutions
and have lots of loosely connected
individual solutions so the kind of
the micro services point of view the api
point of view
and but there's there's value in that
and the value
is that it's a lot easier to manage a
small thing
than is a huge big thing and so for
instance
microsoft is working on a new technology
that they've open sourced
that will allow people to be able to
share
elements within a document and i expect
to see the same kind of
sharing and agility happening with
devops
um the the second area um that i see
is that there is a drive with businesses
and
even traditional businesses that have
been business for a hundred or more
years
to be technology driven um indeed if you
are not
a technology company then there's a good
there's a
a very good opportunity that your
company will go out in business
and this is a very specific niche market
but i would argue that every company is
a
technology company um and they just
don't know it yet
and so we want to be looking at ways in
which
our teams can very nimbly uh take
advantage of the technology but then
also the data
and then really expose and unlock the
value
that can be used by the business to take
the business to the next level
a good example of this actually there's
a company in milwaukee called milwaukee
tools
and they have a
a technology called one log that they
have built into
their tools so anytime on a construction
site that you
the owner of the construction site will
know where all their tools are
the value that you have from that is
that it's quicker to get
to the tools it's easier to ensure the
value of the tools because the tools
themselves aren't going to walk away
offsite
and then probably more importantly is
when you're using the tools particularly
like a
a hand drill or a pneumatic drill
a pneumatic tool of some type
there is a wear and tear
life built into that and so if you can
analyze that data you can actually
predict when
the tool is going to break down and it's
a lot easier to be able to
fix a tool before it breaks than it is
to replace the tool after it's broken
so i can see many more technologies that
are going to
lift up the value of existing
infrastructures
with technology that helps reinforce the
value of that
solution and then um
if i may yeah yeah it's interesting how
pervasive
this effect is because there was a
american politician who was
derided a little bit recently for saying
you know anybody can be a farmer you dig
a hole
you put the seed in the ground the corn
grows anybody can do that
and the part of the backlash were
farmers sending pictures of you know
this is the inside
of my combine harvester
yep i know it very well wall of screens
the gps
locations uh uh things that are
they're talking about the quality of the
the soil the quality of the plants being
grown
much more technology than
most of us use in our day to day you
said
not many fields where technology isn't
um making inroads oh absolutely
absolutely i i um you know ibm have
stated this many times in the past that
uh the the work that ibm will be doing
five years from now 40
of it doesn't exist today um and i would
argue that
we can start extending that reach beyond
technology
to all businesses and certainly over the
next decade we're going to see a huge
change
and frankly covet 19 has accelerated
that change
there has to be investments that are
made digitally
to allow our thought leaders to be able
to work effectively together
so just a couple other points here um
so one of the changes this is a
continued change which is
um there are an increasing number of
small developers
contributing solutions that um
help us within devops and an example of
this
is that if you are a front front end
developer then you probably used
react or angular the number three
uh solution is vue.js um
for a front-end development um view was
developed by one person
it's now open source and being managed
and developed and extended by
a large group of people but originally
it was one person
and that one person helped change an
industry and
that's the mindset you have to have
as an individual developer and
contributor to open source programs
is that you don't have to be a big
corporation anymore
you really don't you can be a small
company and you can
change the landscape so i certainly
encourage
developers to you know help contribute
to that change because
it's always good may seem rough at times
but
uh i always like change and then you
know the final point there is
around brands trying to navigate this
rapid acceleration of digital maturity
um again we've been all forced to go
through this i think that brands in
particular
uh this year have just seen just a
tremendous
uh challenge and you know with with uh
you know shopping malls being closed
restaurants being closed
um the way that we buy our products
changing it has completely
transformed overnight and i think that
in many ways that even if we went back
to
quote-unquote normal tomorrow the new
normal that we'll go into post covid
will be
very different to where we were four
months ago
yeah it's um and
here in california for example
where we had just seen some
businesses being allowed to reopen um
the very next day the governor announced
that they
they needed to close back down things
like hairdressers
nail salons uh fitness centers things
like that where
um we don't know from one day to the
next what's going to happen and these
businesses have to find um
where possible new models for for
working
that yeah around this this uh this
challenge
i was going to ask a related question
when you look at cloud and devops do you
think that um
devops would have reached its level
of accelerated adoption
without the technology of cloud
to enable it uh so that's a that's a
good question
um and i have a cloud bias
um i i think uh i i i'm
um while cloud isn't it i think from a
price point of view i think that
on-premise and cloud can often be um the
same
the opportunities you have with cloud
are unprecedented
uh for instance new technology comes out
i can spin
up an environment cloud in a cloud
environment uh in a matter of hours
i was playing around with a blockchain
solution the other day and i had to spin
up
um five different servers
i had the whole operation up and running
in two hours um
and doing that on premise is almost
impossible to do
i think what cloud has offered is that
tool that next logical uh tool
for acceleration and you you have to
look at cloud as an accelerator
um and then then there's your cloud as a
as a whole but then you look at the
individual
players within clouds and so you have
you know your big players such as
uh microsoft google and
obviously aws um and then you have
niche players as well so you have to
look at how all of them work together
but more importantly is what are the
individual tools and services
that they have that allow you to
accelerate your work so for instance
uh google has some fantastic ai tools
um i'm very partial to the
devops tools that azure has
just the ways of being able to manage
data
um is phenomenal uh with aws
so how do you leverage all of them and
then you know take it to the next level
that's an interesting aspect also of
looking
at the qualitative differences between
platforms
we haven't reached or or will we ever
a point where they're all plug
compatible with each other and you can
just
um well they're getting they're getting
better
they're they are getting better and
microsoft started
so and two years ago um three years ago
you kind of had to make a choice and
you're kind of committed to a cloud
provider and i'm talking about the the
big ones here
between uh the microsoft um amazon
and google what we've also referred to
as the mag
cloud providers um and it used to be
like you you kind of had to throw all
your
all your coins into one bucket um but i
would argue that
um certainly within the last year
they've become um
more um at um
being able to work interoperably with
each other and
microsoft actually had led that way they
started that about two years ago
of being able to leave that out now it's
not as easy
as they make it out to sound um but it's
getting better i think that you'll see
more and more of that and i think what
um will to help differentiate the cloud
providers moving forward
is the services that sit on top of
the core foundational product so you
know your your vm environments your
platform
environments your data environments your
ai
um you know those kind of tools they
will become the
the standard foundation that everybody
will have and then there'll be a layer
on top of that
for developers and devops teams
that allow you to move the data as
objects between the cloud providers and
then on top of that
will be an additional layer which will
be your business power users layer and
and you're starting to see that with the
no coasts and low code solutions that
are coming out
um aws just announced theirs uh
microsoft has their
uh power um platform that they've also
announced and
i think that's going to be an
interesting market to watch over the
next couple years yeah
it's kind of sounds like you're
describing uh how telecommunications
developed so that you ended up with uh
the the different layers um
in that model where yeah
how you can interchange different
providers at each layer
yeah so let's go let's go on and already
started to answer this question what the
new normals look like
what else would you like to say about
that topic um so i think the new
normal i think that a couple of things
um
one of the things that i have liked
about
the new normal we're in is the ability
to work from home
i'm a consultant so i spend most of my
time on the road
monday through thursday or monday
through friday every week
traveling and um and i love i love
meeting with my clients
i love traveling around the country but
i also like hanging out with my family
i think they're pretty cool um and uh so
i have personally
really enjoyed working from home i've
actually found myself much more
productive
i've been able to uh do uh some
activities that i wouldn't have done
before um
and uh so those are one of the areas
that i think just
foundationally i think all of us will
appreciate
more i think that um certainly over the
next year or two
i think there's going to be a greater
emphasis of being able to have the
balance
of working from home as well as working
in the office
assuming that we find a cure for the
kerbit 19.
so that's one thing the second thing
however is as we look
at cloud and devops is that the one
thing that
has allowed our companies globally
to operate effectively through this
pandemic
is technology um and uh we've seen it
with
you know we refer to meetings as zoom
meetings now
and we use microsoft teams we use
skype we use you know any number of
tools
to help us stay connected and
and it's really really helped and i
think that
uh what we'll see certainly moving
forward as part of that new normal
is that uh understanding and that
leveling up um of what can be done
with technology and i think that what
that will
provide the opportunity for devops teams
is uh businesses are going to come
back and say well my customer is now
asking can we do this with them can we
you know how can we start selling
and using these technologies and that's
where devops and cloud
really come into interplay as we start
breaking apart the lego bricks of the
technologies that we're working with and
reassembling them
into solutions that are bespoke
solutions for
our businesses so i think that there is
uh
we're in a period of acceptance of
technology right now and because we've
been forced to level up
and then now that we're in this new
world i think over the next
few months here say like next six months
there's gonna be that realization we can
do so much more with technology and so i
think that's gonna be the next
new thing for cloud and devops is to be
able to rapidly deliver on those
promises
it's interesting because i'm old enough
to remember in the 1980s
in the automobile industry yeah when
the um the dream was that you would be
able to go
to an automobile dealership um
and say well i like this model of car
and i want this and i want this and i
want this and i want this and i want
this
color the interior the different options
they would be able to enter that order
and the factory would be able to
configure your car on all of the cars
being built that day
with all the things you wanted on it and
it would roll off the assembly line
and be on a truck to you the next day
and i don't know that they've ever
quite gotten there in physical
manufacturing
but in terms of software manufacturing
of course you
you don't no longer have the retooling
that
you used to have to change processes
because things have become containerized
modularized
and as you said now you can actually
talk to a customer about
well how can you make this
work for me in particular with my
particular
requirements and needs and you know
that's that's a a fundamental
shift between uh you know from the
the notion of this is how we
took the specification and turned it
into software
now it's this is how we take
components and assemble you the
application you need
so yeah it's interesting you bring up
that
example of the automotive industry uh in
the 1980s because what really powered it
was
lean and um what's interesting is you
take that
same lean mindset and then you
fast forward and 10 years ago um you
know the
the lean startup um book was um
was brought out and took the best of
lean and took the best
of where we were with agile and it
looked at accelerating what could be
delivered
um and then fast forward again to where
we are today and it's just that
continued
uh maturity of that ability
to be able to deliver solutions
that i designed for the moment um so not
only are we looking at having a
car that's built for us we're looking at
having a whole
solution that's designed for us for me
and for you right now um and
i think that's where we're moving
towards
it's fascinating let's go on
please go ahead and address these yeah
so uh so the question was you know how's
cloud and devops work
um how has it changed for us um you know
what's interesting
is um you know we kind of talked about
this but you know the work from home
concept you know
really has companies to rapidly adopt
cloud and you know you look at numbers
such as
you know zoom they they saw in a
three-month period uh
increase of adoption of 160
for all the years they've been around in
three months they
they they more than they nearly tripled
the size of their
footprint of of users
and microsoft has seen the same uh you
know just
accelerated adoption for microsoft teams
and any really kind of uh collaboration
tool
uh should be absolutely accelerating uh
you know
my kids have been using google classroom
as an example so
you know there just has been this
accelerator that uh
that covert 19 has provided and and we
should all
as technologists see that as an
optimistic thing because uh the more
people become invested in technology the
more value
uh the work we do becomes to them
um i think that that uh
the longer we're in covet 19 uh the
greater the opportunities are
for a global workforce and uh
uh certainly i i've worked for a number
of companies uh through my career
uh and some companies are emerging
startup uh very modern technology driven
companies where it didn't matter where i
lived and as long as we all got our job
done
and then there have been other more
traditional companies where they really
wanted me
in an office space um occupying
the same office every day
and i think what we've seen now because
of kovid 19
none of us have those traditional office
spaces and we realize
the expense has come around those but
what it also means is that
as you have a skill the opportunities
for you
to be able to get work through you know
companies like upwork and other places
has increased dramatically because you
don't physically have to relocate and
there isn't
the expense around relocation required
anymore
so i think that's a another huge plus
and
you know certainly if you have any
technical skills you should be
advertising yourself to be able to get
you know some of the the work that's
coming out now
um supply chains are going to have to be
i think reconfigured and localized to
meet
our specialized skill sets uh that's
just
an area that um i see um is gonna change
um i know that amazon is investing
heavily into their own
uh supply chain i believe now don't
quote me on this but i believe i saw
that they were investing something like
10 billion dollars into their supply
chain
and whenever you see a company like
walmart or
amazon making those kind of investments
you have to kind of step back and go
okay
what are they doing and why are they
doing it um and
then the third question becomes should
we be doing it um and so
um and i suppose there's a fourth
question is if you sell product
will we be impacted by what they're
doing um you know certainly i've worked
for companies in the past that will be
impacted um and then the the final area
and and this is more of a specialization
um is with ai ops and so if you're doing
work where you are managing the
operations
of your infrastructure the network
whether it's
in a data center or whether it is in the
cloud
you really want to be looking at those
aiops tools
and you and skilling up on those if
that's an area that you find interesting
so your apm
skills your iteoa skills you want to be
skilling those up because i think that
there's going to be this
significant transition to you um to ai
ops
over the next you know three to five
years simply because
companies can scale then and increase
their digital footprint
without having to dramatically or
equally
increase the the people skills um you
know you can use ai
ops to automate a lot of that work so
that's that's really how i see
um you know the work changing uh over
the next few years
let's move on then i'm going to ask the
audience
another poll question and this one is to
to
ask you about what are the
skills in devops and cloud that you
currently use
here are a few of the names but you can
you may be in
a different position where you are
in terms of your your skill levels today
this is
kind of consistent with the the first
full question which asked about
what positions people are in um because
what i'm seeing
as we're progressing is that
most people are saying that not really
using these skills
right now so it's consistent with the
answer in the first poll because it
seemed like we have a lot of people who
want to learn about
devops about cloud computing and
they're not in that field right now but
would like to
well you know the good thing and this is
one of the reasons why
um i i love working with simply learn so
much is
we provide a lot of materials uh for
free and so we have
articles and ebooks that we constantly
update on
these technologies but we also have
a youtube channel that's just on devops
and so
to get a good foundational understanding
of
the tools that you would need within a
devops environment
for instance we're we're just finishing
up a series of about
12 videos on how to
get up and started with node.js
and the supporting tools that you would
use as a node
developer simply that makes those
available
along with the more traditional
interactive classes
and so it's a great way to kind of get
in and upskill yourself
and make yourself available to that next
um you know that next opportunity
um the other thing that i would then but
i would also complement
while you're upscaling yourself is
being aware of the value that
devops provides to any company so as you
look to solve a problem that's
um in your company um you want to go in
with the mindset of
if i solve this problem how much
money am i going to either save the
company or am i going to generate
and you want that to be that that to be
really your story
uh you and you know a good story always
starts with
how would you like to like make five
million dollars today
and and i'm gonna tell you how to make
five million dollars by spending
three hundred thousand dollars um and
you know that's
that's where these skills really come
into play is as you are
upskilling yourself always think about
the the value you'll be
unlocking because that really then makes
what you're doing absolutely vital to
the success of the business
so i just want to mention that uh as i
said
most people aren't using cloud and
devops skills
in their current work um and that
highlights the value of this webinar for
most of our audience because it will
give you more exposure to
potential so let's move on then
sure and so
what if you were in this
area and you're a
cloud arc solutions architect or devops
engineer um what
other skills should you be
adding to your repertoire
or what what are the areas that you know
somebody wanting to move into the field
yeah should look at as
entry points um so that's a a great
question
and i think that there's really three
ways to answer that question
um the first is do you
have a developer's background yeah for
instance
do you use uh open source solutions are
you a java developer
are you a microsoft dotnet developer
look at what your background is and then
pick
a cloud provider so for instance if you
are
a java developer you may want to
gravitate towards aws
um you're open source you may want to
gravitate towards google cloud if you're
a dot net developer then uh microsoft
azure
makes a lot of sense and and get really
good at understanding
the products and services that are
available for just that one provider
um you know each there's lots of
providers out there and you could spend
a lot of time
getting to know at a very high level
what all the providers offer
um but what will make you valuable is
having a deep understanding of
what one provider does and and then
focusing in on
a specific area within that so that's
the first thing i would do
um the second thing i would do is
look at how i am how you are building
your tools and your solutions today
and how can you re-architect those
solutions
so they are very modular so the example
i always use here
is lego bricks and lego bricks are
fantastic they have
a connector on the top and a receiver on
the bottom where you can
connect two or more lego bricks together
and it is phenomenal what you can build
with lego bricks from building a house
to a
ship to you know i saw they just came
out with lego art
um what they the bottom line is though
is that you have these small
modular components that are very
specific
on what they do and instead of creating
a big mammoth
solution just create one solution that's
made up of
many many pieces that can be
interchanged with each other
and this is why you're seeing uh the
cloud providers accelerating
their services because they're just
reusing infrastructure and foundational
elements
that they've already built so that's
that's the second is making a modular
approach
so but in many ways the third is the
most important
it's changing your mindset and the
mindset
is that um i had this conversation with
my father
um a couple of years ago uh he he said
to me that i don't understand the career
you've chosen
matthew because um i went to school and
i went to college and by the time i was
26 uh he went to
post grad school he knew all that he
needed to know for his career
and he actually worked in the auto
industry um and he goes you know the
next
25 30 years i didn't have to
re-educate myself and um
whereas if you choose the career of
going
down cloud and devops one of the most
important elements of that is
constant and continuous education
so for me i look at what my father did
and it worked out great for him
but i relish the the challenge of
constantly educating myself
and knowing that the information i have
now
uh will will be replaced very easily
five years from now
with an automated system and so i have
to constantly re-educate and re-increase
the value i bring
and so that that's the the third area is
that constant re-education so
pick a cloud provider um choose to
create
modular solutions and then constantly
re-educate yourself
excellent so that reiterates what you
said here
is that um looking at particular
skills and
can you comment on that third one um
so so the third one here and this
actually i'm having a conversation right
now with one of my clients
which is how do you bring devops to
um quote-unquote legacy tools so
um believe it or not um many companies
still have mainframe solutions that
power uh huge parts of their business
um i i'm not a mainframe developer never
have been
but i understand the value that they
bring to companies
at the same time a lot of companies have
invested heavily in
commercial off-the-shelf software what's
often known as carts
and they may have solutions that were
virtualized in a vm environment
very often i get told well i can't bring
devops mindset
to that i can't i cannot bring agile
delivery
uh to these environments and and i would
argue every single day
that irrelevant of what the technology
is
it's still software whether it is a
mainframe solution
whether it is a cult solution whether
it's something that you're building net
new
so what you want to be looking for
is the companies that are making
available the opportunity
that devops has and ai ops as well
to unlock and bring
the the value that devops brings not
just for new solutions
but also for those legacy and
off-the-shelf solutions as well
it's an interesting area in in another
particular respect because one of the
first
things that people complained about when
lockdown happened here in california and
a number of
number of other u.s states was that they
couldn't get through
to file unemployment claims and
one of the reasons for that is that uh
state governments who ran these systems
were using legacy systems that sometimes
dated back to the 70s or the 1960s
yeah and um we're not able to
uh be scaled up to handle the load or
not able to
adapt to changes and rules
so um there's a lot of
interest around the idea of looking at
these
legacy systems in government and in
business and finding ways to
to modernize them without breaking the
bank so to speak so this is going to be
a
a great area in future so let's uh let's
go on
and when we look at the the way people
work together and and
how we organize our our teams
and manage our collective work how
how will we deal with the challenges
that come
up that are presented by this this new
environment like you said we're not
going into an office where we're all
able to
cluster into one meeting room um so we
have to have
different ways of of staying in touch
and managing
our work and the work of others you know
that's a really good question and and
and
this actually impacts devops teams
because for the last
you know five or six years we've been
encouraging devops teams to co-loco
co-locate with each other um you know
particularly if you're
doing power programming where we have
two programmers sitting next to each
other
you know you want those two uh people
physically
in the same room um i think
uh to a large extent you know we
as humans we like to be around each
other and particularly when we're
working on
uh shared projects we want to be
together
however as we move into the business as
usual the
the new normal i think things will
change and i think we have to get
really comfortable with the the concept
of
we don't have to physically be in the
same room
we can virtually be in the same room um
and
the and again you know we talked about
the benefits you know earlier on about
you know working from home that's really
nice and i i really like it
um i have super fast internet faster
than i do in the office
um but one of the things that it does
break down and i think that this will be
one of the changes that we'll start
seeing is as offices
shrink in size and become more used to
using that hoteling uh concept where you
you don't have a dedicated desk you uh
just go into an office and
there's a number of desks and you just
put your
your computer down wherever you feel
like it
um i think what we'll start seeing is
that
um companies still do need to
have people come and interact with each
other
but it'll become more of an event
activity
that we do rather than day-to-day
business as usual
yeah i mean we're seeing that
um it's interesting to see that in the
virtual environment where
there's uh you know weekly check-ins for
teams there's multiple check-ins for
entire organizations um
but again as you say
the notion of convening people face to
face
physically in one space um
i think you're right i think it's going
to become an
exceptional event rather than
and run us through some of these points
um
so you know some of the challenges i
think that
that you'll see is i think that there's
going to be
i think there's going to be short-term
and long-term challenges i think the
short-term ones
many of us are experiencing right now
there's the social um
challenges political challenges uh
fiscal
challenges for many people the
unemployment level
uh in the united states right now is the
highest it's been since the
great depression um and those are
those are short-term challenges that
impact us whether we're doing devops
work
or whatever work we're doing um and
but i see them as being short term so
the next six to 12 months i think there
are
then longer term challenges that
we can be proactive on and that's really
helping our
organizations become prepared for
uncertainty
um so if we go into like for instance
when i'm building a
solution one of the things that we build
into every solution
is security it's a foundation now we
just assume
every solution now is going to be
insecure
um and i think what we have to do is the
same thing
but as from a human point of view of how
we work with each other let's just
make the assumption that we don't know
whether or not we're going to be working
in the office moving forward so
as companies reopen there may be times
when the companies close again and
you just mentioned this in california uh
you know everybody just opened
and now you've closed again i think
we'll see the same thing happen
to other areas of the country in the
united states um and there's talk of
you know potentially a second wave um
you know there's there's so much
uncertainty so instead of
being anxious about that uncertainty
let's build that into our plan
um and then um when you do that then
that allows you to start
positioning yourself for future and
profitable growth
so and you know instead of hoping things
just go away
plan for things to be different and then
you can work around those restrictions
that have been provided to you
and again that will help mitigate
long-term problems
and really it kind of then starts
driving towards
the two foundations of you know becoming
then a more agile operation
and building stability and scalability
into your solutions and that's
fundamentally that the goal of the
devops team
is to be able to have a much more
stable environment that can scale um and
we just take that and we we bring that
as a
a really kind of a
divining rod to how we deliver these
technologies into our organizations
um so let's move on are there
specialized skills that people
need to learn or should be looking at
that will help them become their
organizations become
more resilient in the face of
future disruptions wherever they may go
yeah i think really those specialized
skills really come down to
uh a couple of key areas one is
um how do we digitize the human
interaction that we have
today and um and
and what's interesting is we've been
talking about this for
20 plus years now of digitizing the
human interaction
um and it's never really worked because
we didn't have something that forced us
to
um adapt to that uh new model
and and and also that the technologies
20 years ago were clunky compared to
today
so um people are much more receptive to
that digitized experience
and then the second is to um really
start
adapting what you can do with artificial
intelligence and
and artificial intelligence itself is
just a huge field
of different things you can use but you
know that's
definitely an another area that i would
be looking at
is leveraging the value that ai and ml
and related technologies i can bring to
you the way you engage with your
customers
okay let's uh go on
as you pointed out ai yep so
ai ops as well yeah so if we look at
you know the three um three key areas is
you know it's run the business grow the
business
and then rapid iteration and you run the
business is you're
using ai to manage your network
operations and then scaling with cloud
uh grow the businesses you know devops
whether you call it devops devsecops
sre um these are all terms are really
essentially interchangeable with each
other but it's all about
you know rapidly growing your your
business
and then remaining agile and and the
value with
agile is if you look at traditional
software delivery and and many companies
still do traditional software delivery
you're looking at 6 12 18 month delivery
cycles and in some places um you know
they'll go
three to five years and what covert 19
has shown
is that uh delivery cycles can change
dramatically now
um the the changes that you typically
see are just quite as dramatic as we've
seen this year
uh but then they tend to be more subtle
so with agile
instead of just taking this one linear
direction
you can zig and zag to meet the customer
needs
and and you know and my final statement
there is you know
um you know get a good um understanding
of whether you're working with microsoft
azure
whether you're working with aws or
google cloud and
really good get good at specializing in
one of those
cloud providers um so he takeaways what
have we learned today
so i think a few key takeaways is that
there are skills that have never been in
more demand because
of the digitization renaissance we're
now going through because of covet 19.
um always keep an eye on the future as
devops matures because it matures
quickly
and keep your skills and update it and
and bring that
mindset for devops into your
organization
i strongly encourage build for the cloud
and just will give you
flexibility that building local
on-premise solutions simply can't
provide
and then take that model and build that
in it as a strategy of that opens up the
value
uh within your organization and then
finally become
comfortable working with uncertainty
the last six months have been certainly
very uncertain
i don't think that's going to change
anytime soon so get comfortable working
with that uncertainty and embrace it
because that will help you refocus
how you present your arguments um to
your company for how to implement
different types of technologies and
solutions
my project i realize i've kind of been
overrunning here on the talking
i realized i had muted myself i'm sorry
that's all right that's right
very foolish um but uh yeah please uh
tell us you members of the audience what
skills are you looking to acquire
in cloud and in devops
and maybe whilst people are doing that
we can start doing the questions and
answers
yeah we can actually do that um and what
i'd like to
to start with is
um basic question a front end developer
asks what's the most cutting edge skill
they can look to prepare themselves for
for cloud and devops
um so i think that so this was a from a
front front-end developer
yeah uh so i think um i i you know
get really good at cloud and and cloud
environment changes on a day-to-day
basis i mean just
there are so many services it's really
hard to keep up um
i would from a front-end developer i
would pick
um a technology and get really
really good at it um and sorry a
framework and and
the two frameworks that i would get
really good at are either going to be
react or angular react
i would argue is probably more popular
now
than angular was but both are
are used extensively by many companies
and maturing rapidly and what i like
with both of them
is that they're not limited to just web
applications you can actually build
mobile applications with them as well so
definitely from a
front end development react from a back
end
really good good at node nodejs is
amazing what you can do with it
and get really really good at using that
um
here's a question from nevin who asks
isn't devops more like a methodology to
execute projects using tools
from a wide-ranging toolkit yes so
yes it is a methodology it's also
a mindset and and that's really kind of
what i
bring in when i'm talking with leaders
is that in many instances some of the
tools
you you may have been using for quite
some time and you know a lot of
companies have
implemented um agile and kanban boards
for
you know almost uh 10 years in some
instances
um but when you say devops you're
actually implying
a evolution of how you actually do that
delivery um and that delivery gets
done by having people thinking
differently implementing different
processes
and then yes having tools good question
uh naveed asks
about switching i mean you're going from
an existing legacy environment
into cloud enabled and devops enabled
environments
um is can you comment on
the differences in doing this and the
ease of doing this in service industries
versus product industries
um so that's a very good question and uh
personally i've gone through
that transition and and so i i really
liked having a data center i could go in
i can control the environment
with stand up solutions and what i took
was instead of you know rewiring my
brain overnight what i
i took when i moved from more
you know traditional legacy solutions to
cloud
quote unquote modern solution delivery
was
what can i take that i'm already using
that applies
to this new environment so um you know
you can just transition some of your
skill set because they will transition
very nicely and then when you look at
that
gap between what can work and what needs
what the full skill set you need to have
um start just
tackling that that gap in small chunks
and so you're not having to
uh you know consume a completely
different paradigm
um in one direction because um at the
end of the day
it's it's still software and we've been
doing software delivery for
decades now and so it's it's you know
take what you know
apply it and then adapt it over time
um we have a question
about devops for managed services
can you comment on where um abhishek
asks the question you'd like to know
where he can learn about devops for
managed services
so this is actually very interesting um
and i'm i'm actually working with a
client right now
where almost that same question came up
and when you think of managed
services managed services really falls
into that realm
of uh commercial off-the-shelf solutions
so cut
solutions and and to me that there are
there are three layers of
uh when it comes to cards there's
there's open carts which
um really feel like a devops like
environment
there's closed carts uh where you you
can connect to the system of the
commercial software maybe you can
connect
through connectors or apis
and then you have managed systems and a
managed system is
an environment that's that's very much
locked down
what i would encourage you to do is
really
with those managed systems is you want
to work with
the provider and the first question you
want to ask them is
what is your roadmap um you know what is
your roadmap to
unlocking these systems so that we can
extend the value
that we've invested into this system
the second is maintaining that system is
how can i use a devops mindset for
how i do releases can i apply that to
the managed system
and i may not be able to do it for the
whole system but can i do it
to sections of the system
and then the third really comes into
with some systems is have we
reached the end of the life of this
system
um and for instance um you know i'm
constantly talking to companies about
application rationalization um when we
stand
up a tool within our company
even if only one person is using them
using that tool we tend to be very
hesitant
to remove that tool i think we need to
be
much more bold and brave about
eliminating legacy solutions and
um the the the technical debt that gets
surrounded that
by that so really good question there
we um have a few quick technology
questions
how important is it for a
devops person planning to go into devops
to learn
linux oh i don't think that's important
i mean you know
yes there's a benefit to it but i'm i'm
not a linux expert
um i work on mac and windows i prefer
mac
um so you don't have to be a linux
expert
what you'll find and and this is one of
the the benefits of of the
most of the devops tools that i use is
that
they'll work across all the platforms
and so um because you're working in
terminal window
um or command line to do your
instructions they'll work the same
across all platforms
generally speaking and someone would ask
you to
ask to um address web stack
so uh you know whenever you're looking
at any kind of stack
um you want to be understanding you know
how does that stack apply
and so for instance a typical web stack
would
be um there's one where you would um
we're actually just working on a video
that
this week uh for simply then on the i
believe it's the moon stack where
it's um uh it's mongodb
with express i can't remember what the r
is for
um and then uh node.js um and so
um web stacks are good um
i wouldn't get too hung up on them i
mean a lot of times when you're
interviewing for jobs
they'll say do you know xyz stack um and
and that that that's okay
um but the connectors and the other
tools that come around those stacks
tend to mature and change quickly
and so don't get too hung up on the
stack
look at what is the value of the
individual tools that i'm working with
so for instance
when you're working with node.js knowing
express which is a http
uh also react i know yeah so with with
uh
node.js three tools that work really
well to each other that complement each
other
is the mern stack so that's mongodb
which
is a nosql environment and different two
relational database
um but very popular um there's express
which is a http server um
similar to apache a little bit more
powerful
react js and then node.js and those are
four really good tools in a web stack
that anybody should get to learn um
are they the right tools and for the job
that they may
make change um but there are four really
good tools that show that you have a
full
end and understanding of the technology
and the last question i'm going to take
is uh it seems like a simple question
but
i want to make sure we cover it could
you explain the exact difference between
devops and cloud um so there isn't
so um this goes back to the other
question which is devops is a mindset
cloud is a set of tools uh so you have
tools that are in the cloud
now we used to have them in our data
center on our desktop computers
uh we've just now moved them into a
virtualized environment that's
that we call the cloud uh devops is the
mindset
it's the the people skills it's the
communication skills it's the
the processes as well as the tools and
the tools
uh you'll find uh are local tools uh for
instance
installing um you know you'd run node.js
in your cloud environment with express
um but then you may have
a react that you're working with locally
um so it becomes
you know cloud is the where the tools
are and
uh devops is the mindset you bring to it
okay
very good um so before we uh
finish the webinar i just want to share
the poll result from the last poll
for a moment and people have a broad
range of
skills that they like to learn
okay um i want to thank you
matt for um joining us today and sharing
with us your expertise
can you tell people how to get in touch
with you the best way to get hold of me
is on linkedin i have my linkedin
uh link there but you can actually go on
to linkedin there aren't too many
matthew davids out there
um you can do a search for me and
suddenly reach out
and also i do a lot of videos and
articles for simplyland so
you can find me there as well wonderful
and i hope
people will connect with you i hope also
that people will connect with simple
learn
yes matthew there you go
um so we're on facebook twitter
and linkedin and you can connect with us
on any of those platforms you can
contact us
you can see what we do at our main
website
and we want to thank you for being here
at
this last episode of the step into the
sunlight series
we hope that these webinars have
helped focus you on the future and what
life will be like as we progress through
this
covid 19 pandemic environment and
hopefully
as we said step into the sunlight after
this darkness so
thank you again for being here we will
be having future webinars please keep
an eye out for emails from us announcing
those
we have a expert webinar coming up next
week
with the chief data scientist of airtel
corporation
and probably love to
listen to that so again watch out for an
email for us
or take a look at our website that's the
end of the webinar
so thanks again and thank you stuart
this is great talking
thanks matthew